rock back in the day like when we went
out and did things after the shows were
a big group of manly man we went out to
bars we went and did different things
Rock went and sang karaoke right so you
can laugh about it back then he's gonna
st. Cary okay well let's go get some
beers he's making movies and worth like
billions of dollars and we all need to
spend more time at karaoke the rock I
mean do you think it's changed things
for all wrestlers I think he's paid the
way absolutely the work that rock is
done in the commitment that he's made to
to transforming and transcending the
industry and even though work the day
Batista's done both those guys have
gotten Hollywood's attention in the
studio's attention so I remember 22
years ago if I came out here in
Hollywood they found out I was a
wrestler okay okay they wouldn't talk to
you but now because of the quality work
that Rock's done and Dave's done that
it's opened up opportunities for me to
actually sit down and have a serious
meeting with studio here so you could be
in a movie I could yeah all right
[Applause]
you